this video was made possible by
curiosity stream when you sign up at the
link in the description you'll also get
access to nebula the streaming video
platform that Wendover is a part of the
Wuhan coronavirus began like all new
viruses with a remarkably ordinary
moments in late November 2019 someone it
is not yet known who ate a wild animal
that by chance carried the novel
coronavirus and days later started to
feel the symptoms of what initially
seemed like a bad cold from there more
individuals were infected at first
through the consumption of other wild
animals later through direct human to
human transmission for the entire month
of December the virus was there in Wuhan
spreading but nobody knew it the case is
presenting as pneumonia were at first
considered to be caused by any one of
the countless other viruses that can
create such symptoms prevention the
escalation in cases an effect that
almost all the first patients had bought
food at one particular wild animal
market caught the Wuhan City
government's attention the first
official confirmation that something was
up came on New Year's Eve December 31st
when the Municipal Health Commission
published a press release acknowledging
the situation over a month after the
first transmission at the time this was
small local news only a few dozen cases
of pneumonia in a city of millions in a
country of a billion but then came the
news that this was not one of the many
pre-existing pneumonia causing viruses
this was something new Western media
first reported on the novel coronavirus
around January 8th the New York Times
foreboding Lee wrote there is no
evidence that the new virus is readily
spread by humans and it has not been
tied to any deaths that would soon
change on January 21st when the World
Health Organisation's started tracking
the outbreak there were 282 cases the
next day 314 the next 581
than 846 than 1320 than 2014
and by the start of the week of January
26 it was clear that this would not be a
quick and painless virus this would be
one for the history books and it was
going to get a lot worse before it got
any better drastic circumstances called
for drastic action it was clear given
the trends that Wu Hans hospitals would
soon be overwhelmed by patients and in
the case of highly infectious viruses
like corona virus that makes a bad
situation worse as infected individuals
will try to recover at home where the
virus can more easily spread therefore
the decision was made on January 23rd to
build a brand new facility capable of
treating 1,000 patients at once both
Shenzhen Hospital it was announced that
this would be done fully constructed by
February 2nd just ten days later
China has experience with such a feat in
2003 the country suffered an outbreak of
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
SARS which is also caused by a form of
corona virus much like with the novel
coronavirus hospitals were overwhelmed
and many had to turn away patients in
response the government decided to build
a new hospital over six days 7,000
construction workers brought the xiao
tong shun hospital into reality and it
quickly began accepting patients and
we're leaving the overstressed medical
system once the outbreak settled down
the xiao tong shun hospital was hailed
as a massive success by both the country
itself and the World Health Organization
the statistics speak for themselves over
all SARS had a fatality rate of 9.6
percent of the Shelton's in hospital
just 1.2 percent of patients died and
not a single staff member was infected
it's no wonder why China wanted to
replicate this and therefore xiao tong
shen was the model for the new
coronavirus hospital but this time would
be different
the 2003 hospital began construction
over six months after the beginning of
the outbreak the 2020 hospitals started
construction less than two months after
the first case and just days after the
seriousness of the outbreak became clear
there was far less time for planning and
design the orders came and then it was
immediately time to start step one was
finding a place to put the hospital the
location selected was previously just an
open field about 14 miles or 22
kilometers from central Wuhan this kept
it away from the dense urban core where
further transmission might be easier but
the field in question was also right off
a large pre-existing road which made
access easy that road was quickly shut
down and turned into essentially a
parking lot and staging area for the
project the contract for this project
was given to China Construction third
engineering Bureau company a subsidiary
of the state-owned China State
Construction Engineering Corporation by
revenue this is the world largest
construction company and it has
experience in enormous projects like
Beijing's new airport Egypt's new
capital city and Tesla's Shanghai Giga
Factory if anyone was going to pull this
off it was them to begin construction in
earnest they first needed to prepare the
selected site that involved first
cutting down all the trees and shrubbery
and then perfectly leveling the ground
out of the 10-day construction timeline
this took longer than one might think
about 48 hours this was due in part to
the fact for the project it was
significantly understaffed in its first
few days as they scrambled to find
workers especially as it started
coincided with Chinese New Year's once
the land was leveled though they moved
on to constructing the building
foundations by Sunday January 26 for
this they used a layered system on the
bottom an 8 inch or 20 centimeter layer
of sand was placed then what's referred
to as a geotextile layer a form of
fabric then a layer of waterproof
plastic than another geotextile layer
than another layer of sands on that they
then poured concrete which tried over a
few days but then came the truly
impressive element constructing the
building's themselves in a matter of
days what made this possible was the use
of prefabricated elements modular
constructions such as this has been on
the rise recently it's now a
well-established technique for the
construction of buildings large and
small the idea is same
that somewhere off-site a number of
identical building elements are built
then they're shipped to the construction
site and put together this has plenty of
advantages first and foremost the use of
identical elements built in a factory
system to construct a larger building
lowers cost through economies of scale
then when you actually get to putting
the building together on-site
construction time is significantly less
which once again lowers cost in this
case though cost was not the primary
concern speed was and modular
construction is the fastest way to build
most of the site used a type of
prefabricated modular construction
common with temporary buildings while
it's non clear which company produced
the prefabricated components it is clear
that they existed before the project
started the first building elements
started coming together on Monday
January 27th just four days after the
project broke ground they began by
building the skeleton of the modular
units each of these units was about the
shape and size of a 20 foot shipping
container and this skeleton form
included just the floor ceiling and
structural supports at each corner
throughout this all separate teams out
of these thousands of workers there
started to hook the site out to
utilities like sewage water electricity
and Internet
much of this just involved bringing in
the state-owned companies responsible
for these but for Internet's and the
subsequent building out of an IT system
private companies like Huawei and Lenovo
got involved this was no doubt partially
because the construction of this
hospital drew considerable public
attention in China it came to represent
the physical manifestation of the
country's response to the crisis and
also of China's engineering might the
construction process itself was streamed
by state-owned broadcasting companies
and up to 18 million concurrent viewers
watched the process nearly every major
broadcaster in China reported from the
site publishing footage like what you're
seeing now although very few Western
broadcasters were there this is part of
the reason limited detailed information
and footage of the construction exists
outside of China state-owned
broadcasters where the government can
manage the story and what gets out it
was no doubt viewed as an opportunity by
the Chinese government
time when it faced intense criticism for
its initial response to the outbreak but
of course to gain that praise the
project needed to be successful on
Tuesday January 28th significant
portions of the first building were
completed while the rest of the
complexes foundations were finishing up
over the 29th and 30th more of the
overall structure came to be as the
walls were installed on and in these
skeletons of buildings and work then
began on turning these empty buildings
into a hospital each patient room was
outfitted with two beds some medical
equipment and a bathroom considering the
hospital is built with quarantine in
mind there are some unique aspects to
the design of these rooms for one the
ventilation system is built to keep a
negative pressure in all quarantine
areas so that air will go out through an
exhaust system rather than out under the
door into the rest of the hospital well
at the time of writing it's not entirely
known to what extent this corona virus
can spread through airborne transmission
a ventilation system like this is
standard practice for any quarantine
ward in addition to individual patient
rooms separate areas were designed for
patient processing diagnostic tools like
CT scanners were installed and other
crucial aspects like offices break rooms
and canteens were built in over the 31st
of January and first and second of
February the final areas of the complex
were built up the interior installation
was wrapped up and all the systems were
tested to assure that the hospital was
ready to bring in patients meanwhile
eight People's Liberation Army transport
planes landed at Wuhan Airport carrying
the military medical staff who had
staffed the hospital they moved into the
facility throughout the same day
February 2nd then throughout the night
workers put the finishing touches on to
the hundreds of rooms then the next
morning the moment that ten days prior
seemed impossible arrived the first
patients transferred from other
facilities were wheeled into hua Shan
Shan Hospital and thus marked at the
beginning of its operations they started
with just a few dozen patients but in a
matter of days
this ballooned to hundreds hua Shan Shan
Hospital was only the start of China's
plan to ramp up the number of
beds in Wuhan just three days after
Washington's opening another even larger
Hospital correlation Shawn opens its
1600 beds and 32 wards were built in
just 12 days meanwhile other hospitals
were converted to isolate and treat
coronavirus patients and stadiums and
exhibition centers were turned into
hospitals as well still though even with
this swift decisive action reports
indicate that many of those with milder
cases of coronavirus are getting turned
away from hospitals in Wuhan it
unfortunately seems that coronavirus
with its tremendous severity is one of
the few things that can help pace China
if you want to learn more about how
viruses such as this work from a
biological perspective curiosity stream
has a fascinating short documentary on
one previous epidemic the Zika virus
there's plenty in there the plies to the
current coronavirus outbreak and this is
just one of thousands of top quality
nonfiction shows and documentaries you
can watch on curiosity stream of course
the library you get through a curiosity
stream subscription is now much larger
thanks to their bundle deal with nebula
the streaming platform created by myself
and loads of other educational creators
we main emulate to be the home of our
big ambitious projects my next nebula
original a TV length documentary is
being filmed right as this video comes
out and will release exclusively on
nebula very soon to make sure you get to
see that along with all the other great
originals by other creators sign up for
the curiosity stream nebula bundle deal
a curiosity stream comm slash Wendover
it's super simple any subscription there
comes with nebula and only $20 a year
this is the best deal in the streaming
world